at the world economic forum in davos
every year youtube sets up a production
booth and advice the president's
dignitaries and for leaders in
attendance to stop by and respond via
video to your questions and ideas about
the world's most pressing challenges so
what do you want to ask the world
leaders in davos pose your idea or
question in video or text and submit it
at youtube.com forward slash davos you
can vote on your favorite submissions
from others to will pose the top voted
submissions to the world leaders at
davos when they come to the youtube
booth giving you direct access to some
of the most powerful and influential
people in the world go to youtube com
forward slash Davos today to join the
conversation